let's talk about GMOs just amazing
imagination and how he crafts he's this
world that is both frightening and
exquisitely beautiful well you know I
think Guillermo finds beauty in places
many of us would fear to look I think he
I think he has such an extraordinary
imagination such a such a precision as
such a rigor he said he's able to
contain things in his mind and turn them
from and look at them from every angle
and then and bring them to life in the
most incredible way it's really unique
it's really I I I'm I'm I'm in awe of
his thoroughness he's incredibly
thorough he doesn't just have an idea
and and just throw it out there he has
an idea and he pursues it and and he has
an answer for everything this house is
alive yeah talk about just this location
and what it how it contributes to the
story well the house itself was truly
breathtaking the first time I walked on
I was awestruck and it's never happened
as soon as you walk on two beautiful
sets and you go this is great I walked
onto this I walked through that door
into the house they looked like that and
it was incredible it was it was so fully
imagined and so completely realized and
Jessica could run down those stairs and
and and the the landing contained the
weight of a techno crane if you step on
the floorboards this crimson booze would
seep out from underneath like the clay
underneath the house my first day I was
with Mia in the bedroom and I was
stoking the fire sort of looking into it
with a tortured soul and and suddenly in
the house it felt like the house truly
took a breath and inhale of breath and
it was it was kind of magical love is
both
transcendent and frightening in the
story talk about the love story in this
yeah love is love is a force love is is
is a force of change and and it cannot
be controlled and love if repressed can
twist and it could be deformed and mish
and get misshapen and I think really the
film is about a kind of a battle for who
gets to who gets to love and whose love
survives whose love of the three or four
characters is the most sincere and in a
way it's also about fear as well and how
fear can fear can obstruct love and fear
can poison love but I hope when people
see the film they find out for
themselves what love is what can
audiences expect when they sit down in a
theater to see this I thought I want
order I think audiences can expect from
crimson peak a love story and a ghost
story and that the ghosts come from the
the secrets of the past where love has
been buried and broken and so that love
story in the ghost story er interlinked
you